sauver les meubles c'est l'objectif du
secteur touristique espagnol alors que
la circulation du virus reprend de
manière inquiétante dans le pays
un domaine d'activité qui pèse pour 12%
du pib espagnol une saison estivale plus
que jamais eu mal engagée les décisions
de certaines capitales européennes font
craindre le pire à madrid paris avait
déconseillé dès la semaine dernière de
se rendre en catalogne berlin en a fait
de même mais a également visé deux
autres régions l'aragon et la navarre
mais c'est la décision de londres de
réintroduire des mesures de quarantaine
pour tout voyageur en provenance
d'espagne ce dimanche qui a causé la
colère de madrid
je pense que les décisions prises dans
cette affaire par le royaume uni sont
inadaptées car il ya de nombreux
territoires dans notre pays qui ont une
incidence cumulé en termes de
propagation du virus qui est inférieur
non seulement la moyenne européenne
non seulement la moyenne espagnole mais
aussi à la moyenne plus faibles du
royaume uni gars d'el reno premier
contingent de visiteurs étrangers avec
près de 18 millions de touristes les
britanniques sont une clientèle est
essentielle pour le tourisme espagnol
mais boris johnson reste inflexible sur
cette décision
pour le moment nous devons nous en tenir
aux conseils que nous donnons nous
venons de donner des conseils sur
l'espagne et d'autres endroits dans le
monde
ah je crains que si nous voyons des
signes d'une deuxième vague dans notre
pays
elle se sera vraiment notre travail
notre devoir d'agir rapidement et de
manière décisive afin d'arrêter les
nouvelles infections a d'empêcher les
voyageurs de revenir de ces endroits et
de propager la maladie
ici au royaume uni des choix qui ne sont
pas toujours bien accueilli par les
vacanciers je pense que c'est vraiment
idée stupide d'imposer une quatorzaine
c'est pourtant un endroit magnifique je
n'ai jamais été dans une ville où les
gens sont si sympathique et si gentil je
pense que tous les hommes devraient
venir ici et devait ignorer ce que dit
le gouvernement britannique
c'est comme une prison d'être là bas on
ne peut rien y faire
je trouve cela très exagéré je pense que
cela s'est bien passé je me sens en
sécurité quand les précautions sont
prises
je me sens en sécurité preuve de
l'inquiétude concernant la fuite des
touristes la région de madrid vient de
décider de nouvelles mesures pour tenter
de freiner la reprise de l'épidémie de
kovy 19 une urgence sanitaire mais
également économique selon des chiffres
officiels en espagne la pandémie de kovy
10 9 a détruit plus d'un million
d'emplois au deuxième trimestre en
grande majorité dans l'industrie
touristique